bitcoin has made small fortunes for
millions of people
around the world in fact if you're
watching this video
it's likely that you or someone you know
has made quite a bit of money
investing in bitcoin however all of our
gains are just pennies in comparison to
the world of bitcoin mining
so here's the inner workings of bitcoin
mining and why it's so difficult
starting off let's take a look at how
profitable bitcoin mining can be
clean spark a company involved in
bitcoin mining revealed that only cost
them a mere six thousand dollars to mine
a bitcoin
considering that a single bitcoin runs
upwards of forty thousand dollars today
it's no question that mining companies
are set up to make quite a bit moving
forward
but how exactly does bitcoin mining even
work in the first place
well bitcoin miners are essentially just
auditors
they get paid to ensure that each
bitcoin transaction is indeed
legitimate this system is designed to
prevent something called double spending
from happening
double spending is when someone uses the
same bitcoin to make multiple purchases
for instance someone might try to pay
for starbucks and groceries using the
same bitcoin
in such a scenario it would be the job
of the miners to basically flag one of
the transactions
as illegitimate and cancel transaction
in order to do this miners go around
verifying block
by block each block is just one megabyte
worth of bitcoin transactions
and this is where the tedious work comes
in people often describe the stage as
being heavy computation
but really nothing specifically
challenging is really taking place
it's really just brute force imagine
your friend gave you his iphone
and it has a 40 pin password he wants
you to verify what the password is
and he gives you a couple of hints for
instance he might tell you that the
passcode is above two thousand
but less than eight thousand given that
there are six thousand numbers between
two thousand
and eight thousand this task should on
average take you about three thousand
tries
bitcoin mining devices are doing exactly
this however
instead of trying to brute force a
4-digit passcode they're tasked with
verifying a 64-digit hexadecimal number
now miners don't actually have to crack
a 64-digit hexadecimal number itself
as that would be nearly impossible even
for supercomputers simply due to the raw
number of combinations
rather miners are tasked with verifying
something called the target hash
which they guess using nonsense nonces
are single-use numbers that are related
to the 64-digit hexadecimal number
but they are much smaller in size a
nonce is only 32 bits in size
while a hash is 256 bits in size going
back to the iphone passcode example
this is the same as your friend telling
you that the passcode is a factor of 10.
this information would reduce the number
of guesses you would have to make from
ten thousand
down to just one thousand similarly a
nonce is simply a condensed way of
verifying a 64-digit hexadecimal number
though a nonce makes the verification
process easier it's still extremely
difficult
currently the odds of verifying a block
on your first try is 1
in 17.59 trillion and
here's the catch simply verifying a
block is not enough to earn bitcoin
you have to be the first miner to verify
the block to get rewarded
to make things even worse every four
years the reward for mining a bitcoin
is halved meaning that only the most
efficient miners will survive
long term evidently the first major
obstacle for mining bitcoin
is the pure difficulty of mining bitcoin
you have a 1 in 17.59 trillion chance of
mining a single block
so having a mining rig with a high hash
rate or a high number of inputs per
second
is required you might have heard about
miners using gaming gpus to mine various
cryptocurrencies like ethereum
but in terms of bitcoin mining even the
rtx 3090 which is a 1500
graphics card is not nearly enough to
mine bitcoin
to have a chance of profitably mining
bitcoin you have to get a bitcoin asic
an asic or an application specific
integrated circuit is basically a
computer specifically designed for one
task
which in this case is bitcoin mining a
popular asic for bitcoin mining
is the antminer s9 which has a hash rate
of 14 tera hashes per second
in other words this rig can attempt 14
trillion different combinations
every single second now that might sound
impressive
and it is but even with all that mining
power you likely get squashed by mining
companies
take riot blockchain for instance
currently they have 6040 ant minor
bitcoin a6
together these boast a hash rate of a
whopping 456 per hashes
per second to put that in perspective if
each of those hashes were one second
long
that number would be equivalent to 14.4
billion years
on top of this riot also has 800 s19
pros being installed within the first
four months of 2021
and they expect that this will raise
their overall hashrate to 1.45
extra hashes per second that's the same
as 1.45 million
million million hashes per second
clearly
they're not messing around and that's
just one bitcoin mining company
there are several of these guys who
currently dominate the bitcoin mining
market
but let's say you're willing to go up
against them your next biggest challenge
will be capital
the antminer s19 pro starts at eight
thousand dollars per unit
if you're willing to invest about twenty
five thousand dollars you'd be able to
get your hands on a solid three a6
considering that you chest 19 pro is
capable of 110 tera hashes per second
your setup would be able to get a solid
332 hashes per second
in total this translates to about 2 211
dollars worth of bitcoin
every single month or 26 910 every
single year
at that rate you could break even in
about a year
but there's still one major component
that we have yet to take into account
which is the cost of electricity
generally we write up electricity costs
as a non-issue when buying new
electronics
but these a6 are power hungry beasts
each s19 pro
has an energy rating of 3250 watts
meaning that your rig will consume 9750
watts every single hour
in the us the average rate per kilowatt
hour is 13.4 cents
and when you factor this in your gains
nearly get cut in half
your profit per month after paying for
electricity is one thousand two hundred
and seventy dollars
or fifteen thousand four hundred sixty
dollars per year
now that's still a pretty great return
on investment coming in at about sixty
percent
but there's one more major concern in
jumping into bitcoin mining
which is the volatility of bitcoin all
of the numbers we just discussed
are based on a bitcoin price of roughly
38 thousand dollars
but bitcoin can easily dip back to 20
000 or
even lower and stay there for years
before rallying once again
if this were to happen you would likely
no longer be profitable
as i mentioned at the beginning of the
video it cost companies six thousand
dollars to mine a single bitcoin
and that's when they have thousands of
top of the line asics working 24 7.
considering their skill they're likely
also able to negotiate lower electricity
prices
with that being said an individual's
cost to mine a bitcoin will likely be
well over ten thousand dollars
and maybe even over twenty thousand
dollars thus
if bitcoin dips like it often does you
would quickly become unprofitable
this isn't that big of a deal if you
believe in bitcoin long term
as bitcoin will likely be a lot more
than 38 000 10 years from now
however you won't be able to continue
mining unless you have large cash
reserves
here's the thing if your mining
operation is unprofitable at the moment
you can't sell the bitcoin you mind to
pay for the electricity
if you sell your bitcoin in such a
scenario you would be selling it for
less than you paid to mine it
at that point it would be better to just
buy bitcoin instead of trying to mine it
yourself if you have large cash reserves
however
it may make sense to pay for electricity
in the meantime
and five to ten years down the road when
bitcoin appreciates once again
you would become extremely profitable
but for the average person
private bitcoin mining is not an option
whatsoever
there are other ways take advantage of
bitcoin mining though
one solution is joining a bitcoin mining
pool mining may be extremely hard
individually but as a group the risk to
reward may be much more appealing
as we all just saw from wall street bets
there is definitely power
in numbers anyways mining pools are just
groups of miners who get together online
and split the plot in proportion to
their respective hash rates
this significantly reduces the chances
of mining a block and not getting paid
at all it's likely that even if the
block you mine doesn't end up paying out
someone else in your mining pool had
better luck another option to take
advantage of bitcoin mining
is buying the stock of bitcoin mining
companies the only problem here though
is that you wouldn't be the first person
to get this idea over the past couple of
months
investors have already bid up the stock
of companies like riot
moreover the stocks of these companies
more or less fluctuate the same
percentage
as bitcoin so you might as well just buy
bitcoin
itself at the end of the day bitcoin
mining can be lucrative
but it is also extremely difficult so
unless you have solid experience or are
willing to potentially burn the money
you invest into bitcoin mining
it's probably best you stay away even
the big mining companies have been
struggling to turn a profit
despite having a pretty low mining cost
you have to keep in mind that bitcoin
was under six thousand dollars a coin
not that long ago also these companies
have been investing
all their profits plus more to update
and grow their various mining centers
as a result most of them aren't even
profitable today
and that just goes to show how difficult
bitcoin mining really is
are you guys invested in bitcoin comment
that down below
also drop a like if you guys think
bitcoin is going to the moon
sooner or later and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you